aquí el mar impone sus reglas o mejor
sus olas si una ola es alta se puede
sortear en su interior si es enrollada
hay que hacer figuras y los surfistas
tienen que explorar la ola de manera
óptima los criterios de evaluación son
bastante precisos en términos de
radicalidad potencia desenvoltura y
también de innovación sumando todo esto
se da una nota sobre vida de los 25
jueces se evalúan el desempeño el
surfista con la mejor nota será campeón
en tokio las olas enrolladas necesitan
un entrenamiento especial son sobre todo
las pequeñas que hay que trabajar de
manera distinta trabajar el tono
muscular se necesita hacer dieta para
estar lo más ligero que se pueda y así
ir lo más rápido posible sobre las olas
pequeñas y los juegos será el instinto
marino el que marque la diferencia
es la capacidad en un ambiente tan
aleatorio como se da en japon de
identificar el lugar correcto
la opción antes de ir al agua de
mantenerse y de tratar de tomar las
mejores olas
[Música]
pararse sobre una tabla en el mar está
práctica nació en la polinesia mucho
antes de la época moderna cuando los
eeuu anexar o en el archipiélago de
hawai el surf comenzó a difundirse en el
mundo entero aunque comenzó como un
pasatiempo se profesionalizó en los años
tener al surf por primera vez en unos
juegos olímpicos ya de por sí la
consagración de nuestro deporte porque
aquí se le está viendo como una
verdadera práctica deportiva y no como
un juego de clase
es un deporte extremo hay muchísimo
peligro y tiene una parte táctica muy
importante creo que si a alguien le
gusta el deporte seguramente le gustará
el surf se pasan daimiel soft para los
juegos olímpicos de 2024 el surf volverá
a su cuna en polinesia en esa esquina
del mundo
los artistas retarán a está guapo la
mítica ola de tahití